today we're going to go back in time to
the early 1990s before all of you were
born and look at some games that I
played when I was in Europe which as you
all know I lived in from 1988 to 1992
and I lived where what city and my
address was come on come on
no no show say this Charlevoix sink on
tois and my zip code was built us all
which is 1060 and who was born in
Brussels no he was born in a suburb
Spencer yeah although theoretically is
where in Excel which is part of Brussels
okay anyway
actually that was a good movie
jean-claude van damme that's the name of
the movie yeah yeah JCVD that's a good
movie yeah gets to make one good movie
all right so we're going to look at the
game that I played in Prague in 1990
this is a very funny tournament because
I took a train to Prague well more than
one train and when I got there I was
supposed to play in the I am norm
tournament but I wanted to play in the
GM norm tournament because my rating had
just risen so I was good to tell the
organisers look and but when I walked in
the organizer said hey can you play the
GM norm section and I was like all right
I'll let you this time much off the hook
okay and I tied for second or was clear
second I forgot I lost one game and it
was a game where I was like winning out
of the opening so that's I should ever
do that again okay so here I'm playing
Peter haba he doesn't know how to spell
his name but he plays pretty well JP ETR
okay he should go on wield a fortunate
buy a vowel all right so I'm why and he
played an opening that I play with black
that's not fair I have black in this
position all the time I always lose but
I have more experience with black okay
and usually with black nothing ever
happens
I play e5 or c5 to quickly than I
resigned okay but I was white okay so I
played Bishop d3 probably Bishop e2 is
better
but only like ten players in the world
know that castles and now h3 put it in H
and this was a move that annoyed me when
I had black because if they cancel I
always play Bishop g4 and then my knight
can go to d7 not blocking my bishop and
I can trade off for that night and play
e5 and then I lose but h3 I don't know
what happens to this Bishop so a lot of
people leave it on CA and some people
play b6 and do something over there
my opponent played c5 actually if I
remember correctly and I don't I played
this against against Sam Shanklin about
three or four years ago in a Michigan I
think it was a weekend Swiss although
somehow I played Shanklin and Schulman
that doesn't sound right and check the
records on that and well white sort of
lost a tempo with age three
so black can lose a tempo with c5
because White's Bishop really shouldn't
be on d3 and if we trade pawns on d4
we're going to get a reversed tarush
Queens gambit where White has the extra
move h3 but the bishop on d3 sort of
strange because it blocks the Queen from
defending and attacking the center okay
so I castled and we traded and I played
a3 so he wouldn't play Knight before I
think against Sam I did play D takes e4
Knight B 495 now you guys don't know
yeah that's what I did
okay and now he surprised me although
this was 26 years ago sada I remember
any of the moves I think you played
Bishop f5 here okay good
still remember 26 years later don't ask
me in 26 more years you'll get your feet
dirty
a lot of dirt on it you're gonna be
talking ken west you know exactly what
I'm talking you're not going to be on 26
years
you could you can hope all you want to
point six years as a nice goal yeah yeah
26 years
Holly give you 26 years yeah the 90s and
night right 90 can't be right
89 yeah 63 yeah yeah no no no see the
over/under 64 any chess player 64
Fischer knew what he was doing okay so a
lot of people don't like when they
double their pawns because their pawns
are doubled on the other hand good
control of e4 so this is perfectly
reasonable for black maybe I'll play
this for black actually I have black in
these positions often when I'm black in
a caro-kann and my opponent plays the
can I say this on the air the chicken
variation I was going to add a syllable
to chicken but I didn't do it is that
two syllables and I play black in this
position I usually my opponent's pawn is
on c3 he finally got it okay good and
yeah I have good results because I get
to put a knight on e4 and usually I
attack on the Kings side King AJ or GA
rar as in the famous game Sinquefield
fine gold which Singh field which fine
goal we don't know but it was Rex Rex
against me
the only rated game Rex has ever played
against a GM and you can guess how he
did okay so I played Bishop g5 now in
this middle game even though I wasn't
really that good of a player yet I was
good enough to do nothing okay at least
I understood that my opponent wasn't
good enough to understand that
eventually he did something okay and if
you've watched the Simpsons every second
of every episode you'll remember the
episode where homers a boxer and they
practice and he hits this glove and
there's a fly there and when he hits it
it the fly just flies away uninjured and
so so most said you know hitting isn't
really your strong suit it says you're
just going to stand there and get
punched until the guy gets tired and
falls over okay so he says we don't
wanna get in a boxing match here so
that's sort of actually my philosophy in
chess I don't really do very much if
there's a fly I don't kill
cuz I'm a vegetarian and then you know
eventually my opponent falls over and I
win yay
as in the game fish herb is Guyer but
was this guy's fatal mistake no you
missed the whole everything I have to go
back now rewind the tape even though
there is no tape no that no no that that
that's the game we're busy i er woke
fish are up Fisher fell asleep and this
guy woke him up not good not a good idea
it was in 1963 I'm surprised you don't
remember being that you're 63 terrible I
was even born yet I remember it come on
wake up over there I'll were you in 63
what no that's so you're one year off
okay I said fly not beetle BAM can
nobody got that dumbest audience ever
I believe you ever addressed you know
initially I thought it was a good eye
here huh yeah I think so yeah it's I
don't know if it's better than other
moves but I mean white square bishops
usually good for white this bishops
always having an issue now they're gone
yeah I don't think I have an attack down
the G file not not yet don't tell my
opponents coming
yeah actually against the caro-kann when
White's pawn is on c3 in these positions
I'm the one who gets the attack usually
down the G file okay so 90 for the point
and if you're playing in the Knights
who's playing in the 9th anybody
Wednesday you come you come choose it
but now Wednesday yeah you're busy yeah
so on Wednesday there's a knights
tournament and I don't ate all the games
with a fine-tooth comb nobody could find
that comb and there was a game Lulu head
and she had pawns she was white she had
plans on d4 and f4 she was all ready for
a night f e5 but instead she hung her F
pawn so you know like if I played here
in tanks that would be more like a Lulu
game okay and why am I making fun of
Lulu she wouldn't get me water I mean I
drove her to the computer store I let
her stand in line for 20 minutes I don't
get any water come on shall I brought me
two waters today and it's like 7:45
right
no wonder you quit you like come on
ridiculous
two waters I've only had seven well
alright 94 and I took on d5 giving my
opponent lots of options should he
blunder his queen as recommended by
certain GMS or should he take the knight
or take the bishop nobody knows does the
class have a guess pretty high rated
class actually pretty high rated class
yeah okay yeah if he takes the bishop
then when I recapture then his this pawn
is defended if I could take the night
also hmm that was - it was 1990 I don't
know who knows what I was thinking
okay how was I 1990 on ken wise how was
I
this game was played in Proximus early
in the year yeah that's right so I was
so I was twenty during this game right
if I lost the game I couldn't get a beer
well actually in Prague maybe so yeah I
probably could okay so he took the night
as suggested by the audience you
probably saw the game you came prepared
see that's what I'm thinking I played
against it okay and everybody takes
everything now the computer says black
is fine
because black is fine but in 1990 the
computer said nothing computers like I
haven't been built yet and I'm like
quiet
okay so rugby one these rooks have to go
to be 181 because on f1 and a1
they're no good now what does this pawn
structure remind you of what opening you
could have said any open to giving you
credit
I was thinking to Petrov I just had a
Petroff game in this line where the pawn
structure was like that okay rook b1 I'm
pretending to threaten b7 probably not
threatening it yeah he didn't fall for
that
so rugby 7-9 takes d4 is probably not
good let's get black that's probably
good
okay so Queen c1 making a battery
Rubenstein's happy I don't know if it's
the chess player or the pianists but one
of those happy right okay and then
Knight a5 is a positional move taking
advantage of the weak white squares and
super defending b7
now queen c1 and Bishop g5 that almost
does something why did I do that I don't
like doing anything okay
rookie one as I espoused earlier and I'm
trying to put my pieces on the best
squares so I'm pertaining the thread in
Bishop h6 I'm pretending to threaten b7
which he defended I'm pretending to be
on the open file I'm good at pretending
okay I even pretended I was married in
1990 because I was also good pretending
okay rook c8 now this is the part of
chess which is difficult all of our
pieces are on the right squares so what
would we do if we were super GM's not
agree to add row repeat was good too
I like that yeah I agree to a draw
because you know we don't know what to
do now all our pieces drop the right
squares we can make a mistake okay but I
was no good at 90 never was the super GM
so no drawers okay Bishop f4 most people
thought I was playing Bishop h6 hi
tricked you
this year before I control a five more
I'm not sure which piece I'm putting
there and I might play Bishop h6 later
when you're not thinking about it now
what move would I never recommend for
black here f6 I would have also accepted
Queen e5 Queen d4 Queen b3 I would have
accepted a lot of answers but f6 was the
move I was thinking of that makes the
bishop ban on g7 weekends e6 it does
stop me from going to e5 so a lot of
people would be tempted to play
something like f6 for defensive reasons
but it makes your bishop pretty bad
okay b6 the guy is pretty good not doing
anything
a4 what's my next move
no I'm white what's my next move I'm
going to take his knight oh wait I can't
this isn't the kids class at one o'clock
I never mind yeah I want to play I want
to have the option of rook b5 kick him
away rook e8 9 c4 makes sense
Bishop h6 now that it's not pin to the
rook ha ha ha I showed him okay f6 blue
ooh okay and he resigned after f6
because he realized what a terrible move
it was okay
f6 does stop Queen g5 you got to give
him credit right okay so I played Queen
g5 I'm doing pretty well
okay I'm six now F six actually makes a
little more sense if we're treating the
bishops because is this ship on g7 isn't
so good with the pawn on f6 but there's
no bishops on the board he stopping 9 g5
and Queen g5 and unfortunately for him
he was getting excited about playing a5
he was like old boy I can play
aggressively that never works
so I rip b5 playing aggressively Queen
d7 takes takes knight h4 whew scary that
move doesn't smell very good because
it's NH 4 no I said NH 3 no nothing yeah
but it wasn't check what am I supposed
to do okay so the point of 9h for nobody
knows is I'm going to attack his king
and my knight really couldn't do
anything here and I'm making it sort of
tough for him to play e5 because I have
5 is pretty weak and I don't have a
direct threat so I'm pretty happy about
that I don't want to think about in fact
this is actually a good trick in time
trouble if your opponents in time
trouble what you normally do is move
instantly and blunder and lose that's
the way you guys roll okay right my
comer what you should do what your pawns
in time trouble is never move and make
moves that have no threats if you
threaten their queen they'll move it
away if you threaten nothing they'll be
like wait you didn't threat nothing then
they have 20 moves to think over and
they can't handle that they're only
looking for the moves to threaten things
okay so now h4 is a good time trouble
move because black has a lot of moves
now okay Knight c4 as recommended
earlier Queen f4 96
rook III sacrificing the exchange more
fee style I get all my pieces into the
attack should he take my rook prob
but he was scared when I play rookie
three today now it was 1990 I was 20 I
thought I could attack and my opponent
agreed so he played King AJ because I'm
gonna play grid g3 anyway
now Spencer Feingold who I think is
related to me but hasn't been proven he
played a game in the Knights last week
and there was a situation where his
opponent could [ __ ] he could check his
opponent but his opponent moved the King
first so that the rook g3 wouldn't come
with check it was reversed collars but a
lot of times in chess when your
opponent's going to check you and you
have to move your King somewhere moving
your King there first where it takes the
sting out of it now you get a free move
a move that's not clear what to do here
I would play Knight takes rook as would
Alex Marlar long is like what's the
problem okay
so King H a rook back Bluff
no more Bluff 94 d5 and I think the
reason I won the game is because of the
move d5 is it a good move yeah it's okay
but I think I put my opponent on the
defensive and it takes his Queen away
from defending his King over here as you
can see none of his pieces are too close
to his King and I have a lot of pieces
that are coming towards his King what
should black do what do you refute d5
where's Larry Evans captain Evans Knight
g5 wait that's too good 95 can I take on
e6 then at 5 is weak now now actually
that h4 makes sense my moves ever make
sense I'll give you the green light
there we go
well if you're dealing with the e pawn
or let me play D takes e6 your f5 pawn
is weak so how do you make your f5 pawn
not weak
Queen d5 is how he played yeah okay and
i blundered upon so I resigned No
okay now his queen isn't defending his
king anymore so I can play Queen h6 and
if he wants to defend with his queen he
has to lose a tempo by moving it back to
the second rank also if I can kick his
knight then this will be annoying and I
can't make my usual annoying junk
because I was only married once at that
time so I joke doesn't make any sense
okay
so he went back to DA defending his pawn
now if I attack his die and I can move
anywhere for example g5 96 check Knight
f4 where's the night going Age 5
I found a good square for my Knight rook
c7 and I put this scheme on the computer
about an hour ago
and I always thought I play great I put
pressure of my opponent and eventually
he cracked and the computer said now
you're terrible in fact it didn't even
give a value of the game it didn't say
+1
it just said you're terrible so I got to
get a new computer ok and it said blacks
better blacks better blacks better
blacks better this attack is nothing and
then you played he 5 and it said all
right now you're better so it doesn't
like to move e5 in fact I think the
computer claims that was the only bad
movie made up until now but I thought
because all the pressure I put on it was
me
right when I was 20 you know something
okay so e5 looks good
threatens my Knight rook d3 attacking
his Queen at night h5 now his Queens
defending f6 his rooks defending g7 his
rook is pinned to his Queen he can't
take my ruck and he's a time trouble
that he was late for his cab and uber
didn't exist yet so he was like ah me an
expensive cab ride ok he played rookie
six defending f6 again and I doubled
rich on the D file he still can't play
rook takes rook because of Queen g7 me
exactly okay and he played rookie seven
now here I have a forced win or was it
the last move yeah actually I have a
forced to win here it's the same fourth
twin that I played but now it's better
so by playing the wrong move I won
easier okay so I traded rooks and now I
played the move you've been dying to
play the whole game and now you can play
it louder Queen g7 now most of you think
that wins the exchange but actually it
wins the whole rook because if he takes
what she didn't do because what did he
do
resigned I take Shak and now instead of
taking the rook instead I play rook d7
Shak and I win a whole Rock yeah so
after the game I was like well I play
great that game like it feels like no
you're terrible yeah it said black was
always equal or slightly better and only
e5 was the losing move but actually
that's not the truth the human truth is
more truth so if you're crazy like I
don't know Jacob okay you don't know him
oh you do know him you work for him
Jacob likes to watch these stupid
computer tournaments which are going on
right now by the way and then the
computer plays the computer and the game
goes 200 moves and Komodo wins I don't
know why he's watching a tournament
where Komodo wins I could I tell him
before he and Komodo wins and he's like
yeah I know and I'm like so why you
watching it okay what's that
the kimono but that's a good joke that's
for you that's really high up there yeah
because because it's a computer it never
plays the dragon okay so uh you know
it's Komodo and stockfish then Komodo
wins yeah the computer just play for no
reason all right now that's why I have
stock fish why should I have come over
when I can have stock fish it's free all
right I mean they're all free but this
is actually for you different kind of
freedom there's free and there's free
yeah oh maybe I feel better if I steal
it all right so when humans play usually
pressure is building when two
grandmasters play one of them sort of
falters but they don't really build
pressure when the computers play just
give some random number so it's much
more fun watching humans play where the
guy gets in time trouble and even though
it's equal he has one move that's equal
and you have all moves that are equal so
it's good to have white in positions
where black has one move that equalizer
gives them an advantage nevertheless he
gets checkmated so as you can see my
King was very safe and his wasn't and
since this was 1990 I took a few more
risks than I normally do I would never
sacrifice a rook on b5 I've never played
d5 I was giving everything away can't
make any of those jokes moving on so
actually if there was a thing here okay
never mind
all right now I like chess face they
called him Vladimir voiceover to Akkad
well cool name okay this was also played
in 1990 and this was played in Reykjavik
and I have a lot of Reykjavik stories
most of them I can tell when I left
Reykjavik it was 30 below zero and I
flew to Luxembourg a four hour flight
and it was 70 so that was a big
difference we'd have to dice the plane
in Luxembourg okay so I was white
against two kuma cough and he played the
Dutch and what are the two things I hate
in chess people who were intolerant of
other people's cultures and the Dutch
exactly now the Dutch isn't as bad as it
seems it's not as Vance's reputation
it's not as bad as its results you
should play the Dutch against me okay if
I play the double round-robin do the
all right yeah you really have wiped
them black yeah we should skip that very
good Wow
you enjoy wow this is amazing okay so I
played the fine gold attack Bishop g5
just in case he pre moves ecigs my comer
is writing that down for later
like who now I did have a game against
the player rated 1150 about 25 years ago
no more than 25 years ago 35 years ago
and he played d5 I played Bishop g5 and
he did play six and it was a slow rated
game and before I took his queen I just
sat there let him see it and then he saw
it and he was not happy you can come in
yeah I have some questions for you too
haha going to your dad instead terrible
alright so Bishop g5 then he attacked my
bishop now every book on the Dutch says
Bishop h4 but I play Bishop f4 to me h6
is weakening
I don't think each six is a good move I
think black should play either d5 or g6
but if I'm playing you play h6 okay and
Knight f6 and now this is a sacrifice I
invented now remember this was 1990 I
don't do this now now I would I would
have offered three or four drives by now
okay by now
fact you remember when I beat Matt
Larson a few months ago I was wide I
offered him a draw move six and somehow
I won the game because he doesn't take
draws but I did offer him a draw last
weekend he took it right my comer you
were there yeah and who died playing the
last round of that tournament might
color alright and my comer had more
points than I did so there you go okay
so I played the fine gold sacrifice I'm
sure Alex Marlar knows it efore hoping
for Ken West Kenny West's put on the
spot here he's the wait I didn't sign up
for this so if you play Knight takes e4
Queen h5 is strong but they haven't
played that yet
darn alright so thanks to the F pawn and
I play nine c3 and I can actually take
on e4 next move if you didn't move
I like this pawn
sacrifice because you got some weak
squares near your King here obviously I
wouldn't play it now because I can't
part with my pawns but I just become an
international minister so I could give
everything away I doesn't matter what I
did
okay d5 I face that in other things f3
never play f3 and I've had people take
on yep three of every one three he
played Bishop f5 and we have a fun
position I'm down a pawn but it's a
double pawn and his King doesn't look
very safe
okay g5 and Knight be five because I
taught a lot of kids back then okay it's
very hard to defend c7 so he traded and
now if he trades Queens his Knights
attacked and c7 is attacked C sevens not
attack now because his queen is
defending it so he moved his Knight and
I played Bishop e2 retreating because it
attacks his night and I didn't see a
good place for his nights ago and again
if he trades Queens that c7 pawn is
going to be hanging he saw a good place
for his knight 95 when I checked then he
played Knight f7 so black is up to pawns
but I'm attacking on both the wings and
the center but still we have to play
like Morphy and develop our pieces okay
now I want to play nine to d4 nine to g3
castles possibly rook f1 which I did
play and he played a six now this is a
very important part of the game I played
g4 because bishop only has one square
and now it seems very obvious to attack
this knight on the F file there's two
ways to do it
rook f1 or castles and one way is better
than the other will somebody explain why
vision check man just random answers but
that one's right yeah if I cancel
he can play Bishop check and then he
could castle but if I play rook f1 now
he can I mean he Bishop b4 check C 3s
pieces are still hanging so I'm down to
pawns but I have some initiative okay
and also the two pawns I'm down or very
suspicious okay how did he defend his
Knight I'll give you a hint
David Bronstein that's good him bishop
g8 got defend that night and when I
played the move Knight d4 it's very hard
to defend your e6 pawn because if you
defend it with your Queen I take it
anyway and if you take my knight I have
97 track and so when he made the next
two move for many years thereafter
making fun of my opponent and all of all
of chess in general I said ah the Soviet
school of chess King e7 Bishop GA King
e7 now I know how to play chess okay now
this is now two macaws a great guy like
him he's working with Fabiano now
another one of my favorite customers
anyway so this is the game i beat to
akov you're not allowed to see the other
games I play to click off no no this is
the only game other games you can look
at okay and this is very funny
after the game we analyzed this reminded
me of my game with Carlos Jimenez plays
the chess club here a few years ago when
I won that game and we analyzed it with
a Webster team they were like you should
go here and he should go there he was
sort of laughing along and he had a good
time and took work off his upon his
friends Russian team was there they were
like your opponent should have beat you
this way and your opponent should have
beat you that way
he was like be quiet because they were
finding improvements for me and I really
beat him bad so he didn't want to hear
that he wanted to hear improvements for
him but okay here I think it's already
too late so took macaws yeah I could say
anything you guys have to believe me
uh he was good he was
like 2,600 feet a which now is like
2,800 now he was he was top hundred in
the world maybe like hundred that um
okay so queenie - i'm actually get one
of my pawns back and I'm going to castle
I don't have to win right away because
he just can't untangle so he tried to
untangle and I got one of my pawns back
now do a lot of rook lives takes the now
I'm threatening rook FA which is very
annoying and that was sort of a cool
move if we trade everything on f7 then
my rook on f7 is annoying because I got
Queen b7 and Rick p7 so he went to
Castle by hand and I went there
attacking his rook that was pretty
annoying
you can't pin my bishop because I play
Queen c4 check and then I play Queen
takes rook check and then you resign so
you sort of actually have to take month
you have to take my bishop and this is
just a mop-up now I was in mild time
trouble here and in this position I
played the move Queen d3 overlooking
Bishop g4 but you can't blame me that's
hard to see Bishop move diagonally come
on
luckily didn't matter so I just tried to
make my King safe and I did a good job
my King was pretty safe and the best
part of the game was here because after
Queen check King here stopping Queen b7
mate I played rook f8 rook F mates not
only a good move it was move 40 the time
control was it move 40 that was even it
was even better than I was I moved for
you than it was winning because now I
did wasn't worried I'd lose on time I
probably played rook FA with about a
minute left and then I was like hey I'm
meeting him but more importantly I'm not
losing on time okay and even though
Queen and Bishop was better than Queen
and night it's not better than Queen and
rook okay so that was a relatively easy
win against somebody pretty good and
that was a real heartbreaking tournament
there were eight million GM's as far as
I remember and I was just become an IM
in the last round
I played somebody with the exact same
rating as me
and I had white and if I won I tied for
first you can guess how I did I did not
win and actually if I drew I still win
no money it was a ten way tie for first
and I would have won 3000 if I had won
and I lost so I got my usual nothing but
my pawn got 3,000 yay
I actually had a good tournament until
the last round okay but it was nice
weather
it wasn't my special erling Mortensen
you're like what yeah that's correct
no alright last but least okay so this
was a funny game because I want a prize
for this game now this was a 92 when I
was you know more seasoned okay because
I like to put seasoning on my food and I
ate a lot of the 90s so and I played
Cherokee on de Boer okay not part of the
Boer Wars and said that's not that's a
different Devore and as you know in
Dutch for the Dutch people member you're
where do you go
he left I was going to talk about his
Dutch lecture what is de Boer and Dutch
you guys didn't be W it's the farmer
okay he's a farmer now this is quite
funny the reason I sacrificed all my
pieces and when the brilliancy prize
wasn't because I like doing that I hate
doing that I hate winning I hate
brilliancy I everything but the previous
round I was white I get white every
round against Patrick wolf and there was
the most boring him ever I was white
Negrin felled all trades draw seventeen
moves no pieces on the board and I was
why yeah and I was white against in
another grünfeld
and I was like again and I was like okay
now we're going to go crazy and I played
the craziest I could and that was more
fun okay so I don't play this slime with
white but I did anyway and here
everybody in the world plays c5 and he
played a line that he knew that I didn't
luckily I didn't know any line so I
didn't matter okay now what's the
craziest move you can play Age 4 yeah
and he actually knew like 70 Musa
theories he played faster than I did and
h4 is actually a book move no that's a
totally that's a different line
okay so this is all theory News playing
instantly but I was making it up and
this is still theory yeah okay and
there's a game the Tim on his countryman
one I moved 22 and it was 18 was a
theory so that didn't work out well okay
Bishop a six-night g3 Queen g4 this has
all been played before so he was playing
quickly this was his prep and I didn't
know anything after like b6 well I knew
it was wild and crazy okay and then well
I played a very famous rook sacrifice
I'm sure you're all familiar with that
means they're not for ya and the next
day at breakfast I was talking to my
homies course Trey and Bronstein and I
was like I sacked a rook and Bronstein's
like you prepared a rook sacrifice I
said no I didn't know anything extra
move seven yeah again yeah course I used
to be my fan then I don't know what
happened
I started playing bad boy yeah okay and
I played the most obvious move no it's
not obvious
yeah well I'm already a move off Bishop
d5 is the most obvious now I played the
most obvious move me in 24 years later I
remember the games at all okay this is
actually all been played before here I
played rook h5 as recommended by me I
was young then I could play sacrifices
okay so if you don't take my rook I'll
play Knight f5 check and then when you
take my knight I'll play rogue g5 check
right and also if you don't take my rook
I might play Queenie h6 check you never
know so I took my rug okay and I put it
in check it's not Knight f5 it's it's
knife f5 right okay so King g6 is risky
because of Queen h6 mate kingi it's
risky because of 9 h6 check winning your
Queen and if you play King h8 then man I
hate to make extra moves because we're
going to have to then I can go check and
here and I'm threatening 97 million
it and I'm threatening to take your
Bishop also these pieces are pretty good
okay so he played the obvious move the
one I didn't tell you yeah
King f6 okay happens I took the night he
didn't want me to take all of his pieces
cinch it back and I checked now he has
two ways of playing king g6 isn't good
because Queen h6 is still man he played
King e5 now the best analysis I did with
this game was with yasser Sarah Juan and
I was very nice to him in the last
lecture okay and yes so now we're eating
in a very nice Italian restaurant
vikon's and in the city with other
people and I said did you see the game I
won today and he said oh no no and I was
like oh he's like tell me the game so I
told him the game and he was like nom
nom and he was like why didn't you go
here and why didn't he go there and
these were the notes I used for my game
because he was right okay and we
analyzed King e6 a little bit again this
is 24 years ago check check you can't
play King takes knight as a queen d5
mate and this is a very interesting
position i think computer says it's
equally gives us everything is equal and
he took which is fine and he played King
e6 king f4 doesn't work because at the
very least King here is made so that's
good for white and if he plays King f3 I
have 9 h4 and his only legal move his
Queen takes Knight so I would take white
there so he didn't play any of that you
play King e6 and I played f3 because my
e pawn was attacked okay also now I can
Castle okay and his Queens attack so he
moved it check and again he can play
King d7 it's possible and I'll castle
Wow and he'll go here and I'll take and
it looks like white should have at least
enough for the exchange so he didn't do
that he moved up in the world
King e5 I took a bishop and here he made
the losing move and it wasn't because he
was worried he thought he was winning he
was like oh boy I'm finally winning and
the game could have ended Queen g1 Queen
G to draw greed or I can walk my king up
which is very risky which I probably
would have done because that seems like
a boring draw Queen G 1 is equal the
movie made losses but he thought he was
winning and it's funny I've been
teaching my students this ever since
this game a lot of times when somebody
is attacking they miss an attacking move
because that move is a retreat normally
they're going forward when your opponent
retreats and it's strong those moves are
often overlooked as it was here so
computer still says it's equal um
although if he takes my rook which is a
bit crazy okay then then that's not
equal anymore check I think this go here
here King here Queen everything's made
every legal was made so that's better
and then made actually member these
variations from a million years ago okay
so he played the losing move Queen takes
f3 maybe his only bad what was the game
that I'll teach him to play a bad move
okay and I played Shaq and again if he
goes back it's me it's the same man I
showed you I went his queen everything
is great and he played this and he
thought he was winning he's up the
exchange in two pawns
I can't castle my rook on anyone isn't
doing anything in my Knights hanging
so he's like yeah winning and then I
made them move that he missed and he's
like oh I'm losing darn which move was
that I give you a hint earlier I said it
was a retreat yeah 93 he didn't see 93
he's looking at Queen c6 and Queen b7
and Queen e7 a queen c4 Knight d6 and
all those moves lose 93 wins though now
you can't make these moves because
they're illegal and therefore not good
so his King has to go to a green square
he goes to d5 I can just play queen b7
check winning his queen okay so he
played the correct move King to d3
he plays King to e3 pretty simple made I
think
so King to d3 was forced and I checked
he can't take the pawn because I have
this skewer so he went to c4
if he goes to c2 Queen d2 is still mate
and finally I get another piece of the
attack and if you play King e6 or King
e5 Queen d6 his mate and if you go here
Queen c4 rook d7 and mate okay so he has
to take my rook and finally on the head
material hooray yeah and this was very
funny he was in really bad time trouble
and the game ended on a blunder but his
blunder was the best move you don't know
talking about ken west yeah okay so in
this position my opponent played the
best move but it was a blunder but it
was such a good it was still best
I'm mating him everything is me he
played the only move to stop man rogue
d3 he didn't see his work was hanging he
just checked me he had the it was roof
39 or 40 hit like five seconds left
then I took it he's like oh the computer
suggests rip d3 because his otherwise
you get made it everywhere Queen h7
Queen h6 Queen h5 is matin one and queen
g4 and/or Queen g2 is matin - so Brooke
d3 best that's how good he is when he
makes the worst move ever it's the best
and when the game ended he said like
whoa what what's going on what happened
and then Patrick wolf went out to me and
said were you lucky or was it all like
genius and I said I don't know and then
after the game we analyzed that we
thought I was a genius
and then when I looked at with the aster
what he was playing blindfold it was
clear that I wasn't but the sacrifice is
ok and leads to a draw and then you put
pressure on your opponent their King
runs around the board he made one
mistake Queen takes f3 and he thought he
was winning it wasn't because he was
afraid he was too confident so he's all
my kings active very suspicious so those
were three games I played in the early
90s I don't play like that now now it
should
ten move drawers yeah I can't lift I do
that now I just hang everything like
he'd play rugby I mean I would play
Queen track and he played rook takes
Queen and I can't I can't see one move
ahead anymore so when I was younger
living in Europe I played wild and crazy
chess and then I came back to the US for
my somber boring chess the ones you like
a lot now